hey I'm destiny and I'm from Atlanta hi
I'm Evan I'm from Seoul South Korea hey
guys I'm cute I'm from New York but my
family from the South I'm Jackie
I was born in Korea my family's Korean
I've lived all around the United States
and today we're gonna be trying Korean
versus southern barbecue to see which
one is better
I've definitely had Korean barbecue I
grew up in Korea graduated high school
there but I've never had them like side
by side so I've never been able to be
like which is better I've never been to
the southern part of America at all but
elected music so I think they're
completely different the only thing they
have in common is that they both use the
word barbecue I think they're both gonna
be good for different reasons let's have
no conflict here I love kimchi I keep it
at my apartment
I've never had this before really yeah
it's like the Korean pickle kimchi is a
side and like most Korean cuisine pretty
much any Korean restaurant you go to you
can get kimchi mm-hmm oh yeah
tastes like kimchi I'd never eat clothes
long I definitely think mmm this is good
though I could see this going well with
like seeds guess get some counteracting
flavors exactly I've definitely had
coleslaw I don't have it regularly
I haven't maybe would KFC I Michael saw
before I've never had like homemade
coleslaw or like a coleslaw at a
backyard barbecue good I mean okay good
yeah it's like a little sweet it's got a
little little salt to it this is a
staple for like southern barbecue
personally it's not my go-to if you had
a barbecue you got some ribs
you got some sausages probably got a
hotdog in there and you have some close
long like looking at the two now I could
see how you could compare coleslaw to
kimchi and this of like the cabbage II
sure why hmm I definitely think there
are two different places I think for a
barbecue if I'm eating this with some
meat I think I'm gonna take the coleslaw
just because it says low like spice like
I do like that taste but it was like a
little little much for me I mean that
aesthetic was almost definitely this one
this is just red
you can never go wrong with that so
[Music]
captain is also like a popular side dish
I think my favorite thing about chopped
Shay is like the transparency of the
noodles I think is the most exciting
thing for me
I like this hurry mm-hmm you know this
is so good
honestly like I've had to choose between
this and kimchi I'm definitely only this
the fact that there's some egg in here
is some meat in here as well so it's
like you can almost eat this without
actual like meat entree we got mac and
cheese over here I've definitely had mac
and cheese oh my god I get the macaroni
and cheese mmm good yeah I love it oh my
god that's so good I love mac and cheese
it's good there's a huge difference
between southern macaroni and macaroni
elsewhere for one it's usually baked
it's nice and creamy it's not like the
you know Stouffer's McEntee stovetop
that you would get this all like gooey
you know I mean like this it's just
perfect than what it is having me we've
been through some things and you can
tell it in our food again it's like hard
to like compare the two I love mac and
cheese but I also love tuptim but I
think maybe in this case I actually do
prefer mac and cheese because I like
warm dishes this is a very hard one yeah
both of these guys I can like sit on my
couch and just like just binge eat I'm
gonna have to go with the mac and cheese
dishes on the stick timber roots it's a
type of
oh yeah
oh yes Wow would you look at that blue
bogey is like the og barbecue oh very
good
oh yeah yes I I you guys sweet I like
this
there's definitely a sweeter meat and
the thing I like about bulgogi versus
southern barbecue is that it's very
lightweight any kind of southern meat
it's gonna be very heavy out there Wow
would you look at that oh this looks
really good I can already tell this is
gonna be good mmm I might like these
more because I don't really like to deal
with bones all the time like I'm not a
rib person just because it's messy
specifically so I'm just like yo just
stab it and grab it stab it and grab it
for some reason I like fighting off the
meat off of bone like there's something
about it that gives extra pleasure it's
got that smoky flavors it's good it's
like really good and only getting too
messy while I eat I don't like dealing
with bones mm-hmm but that doesn't take
away from like the deliciousness baby
back ribs is definitely my favorite item
I'm gonna say it's a tie because if I'm
going for something more lightweight
that feels like Korea home I would
definitely go pogodi but if I want to go
to a barbecue I like this one because
it's like easy to eat like you can make
it finger food you can just bite it well
this it's classic it's like nostalgic
for me 5 to choose the soy of these
beyond these two items definitely baby
back ribs I mean this guy is taking the
crown for me
yeah for sure it was a good experience I
mean any video where I just get to eat
food and then that's it it's a good
video honestly I was here because I was
told there will be Korean barbecue hey
baby back ribs boom I thought it was
great I honestly thought both were great
I thought the mac and cheese was amazing
chop Chae is amazing and the beef we had
yeah it was pretty great as well my
favorite item is obviously the baby back
ribs
I mean mac and cheese was also I could
be full for an entire week with those
two
of the things that I tried I would say
my favorite would probably be the kimchi
followed by the chopped Shambo Go game
so their barbecue I think is like a
heavier like meal like I probably could
eat more Korean barbecue than southern
barbecue just because southern barbecue
is very flavorful I think I pretty much
am gonna stand with what I came in and I
think I'm gonna be a rider die from a
southern barbecue I think for the food
wise just the food itself I prefer a
Korean barbecue but like the whole
experience like being in a backyard you
know have the music blasting you know
just chill with your friends have the
grill like I think southern barbecue
takes the crown for that